dr. Sachin man dead car is a man on a
mission and he's crossing the city of
Pune to make a rare house call he's here
to treat Rajiv kid car who suffers from
a chronic skin condition called
psoriasis and the Rajiv is eager for dr.
Sachin to ease his suffering he's more
than a little unsettled because he knows
the cure in this doctors bag is one
that's certain to get under his skin
leeches every year millions of Indians
choose not to visit their country's
modern medical clinics instead they seek
traditional healers like dr. Sachin who
use leeches as part of an ancient system
of medicine called Ayurveda its holistic
approach to treating illness includes
dietary changes curative oils massages
and relaxation therapies and leeches for
dr. Sachin the results speak for
themselves
but even here leeches are often taboo if
I see a leech I can't stand it I won't
even go near it
why would anyone voluntarily allow
himself to become a meal for a blood
sucking leech Rajiv is convinced this
leech will provide relief for his
psoriasis he's tried Western medicine
and it hasn't worked in certain cases
like Rajiv psoriasis dr. Sachin and his
wife dr. kirtan and dead car believe a
patient's ailment stemmed from toxins or
impurities in the blood basically
desired with the concept not in modern
science
Ayurvedic insists that leeches naturally
remove toxic blood from the body we just
applied the leech
due to the local part of body which is
affected to take out the blood
impurities
the method is quite natural and 0% of
hommies dead but not necessarily for the
leech blood impurities are said to be as
dangerous to these parasites as they are
to the patient so Ayurvedic doctors
douse their leeches in turmeric powder
to get them to expel the toxic blood we
just make the leeches to Wommack because
she cannot digest a impure blood dr.
Sachin is optimistic that people's faith
in leeches will continue to hang on by
embracing this taboo treatment patients
keep an ancient cure alive and well